[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back top the record
where we talk about whatever we want and
today we have the media and podcast
personality and internet sensation and
real [ __ ] you didn't want to say that
but you should use his pronouns I was
reading something from an article and it
was like a tweet or something I don't
know but they actually said it because I
was reading it and people got very upset
with me something like never really even
when you're just reading it I bet you're
why people getting upset I'm never ever
ever going to hear he has the coupons
coupons parameters on hearing Kevin I
did I just now got off of tour not too
long ago I'm excited my daughter just
moved in with me she's 14 years old
she's a freshman what she's about to be
14 I'm talking to be living like man I
got some Chinese awesome new you got
some new teeth right really so you know
nah man cuz I just you know I talk right
I have a little one but you have to like
listen for it but yeah you go with
silver instead of gold to match these
laws go sweetheart
oh there's diamonds in there that's why
diamonds diamond dusted
oh damn so yeah so like when I brush my
teeth I brush - dude I'll use to
toothpaste but I use for mouthwash
jewelry cleaner totally kidding no the
metal mouth thing is a response to kids
who had braces like just owning it right
possibly I never thought about a life
yeah because remember kids getting
called metal mouth whole time and stuff
I've never every time I used to see kids
with caps on their tea price guys they
bad eyes always my friend went to a
pimps and hoes party back in combat
there's a pimps and hoes party
it's a hos party so you just like a pimp
or you dress like a ho so she dressed
like a pimp but um she put like tinfoil
on her teeth there's like be a grill and
she got drunk and passed out that way
and then when she woke up there were all
kinds of holes in her teeth like tin
foil like [ __ ] you folks your teeth
but don't do that with the beer probably
like yeah yeah like she woke a [ __ ] like
holes all up in her teeth there's never
get a whole new yeah completely had to
redo her teeth veneers and [ __ ] yeah so
just like just so you know if you want
you think it's real cool to put tin foil
on your teeth I love the excitement over
I'm gonna be a pimp
[Laughter]
go to sleep ya know I recently got
attachments puttin in my teeth and I
hate them you can probably see the way
yes I have Invisalign and like they
added these little if I have the
aligners put in you could they're way
more noticeable because they like stick
out too yeah it creates like a shadow
around the attachments the point of the
attachment so it's so the aligner could
grab onto my tooth and shift it faster
and better I don't know but I'm like if
I knew because I'm pissed because I
didn't know I was gonna get them yeah so
I was just like what the [ __ ] and then
Bose told me she got them too but
they're behind her teeth so you can't
hold it how did you not know you were
gonna get them did you just wake up and
a doctor just had it in your mouth
you're like no I was gonna get them when
I signed up for it like I think they did
like briefly mention it but I didn't
know it was gonna be like this and like
all across my front of basically braces
exactly because every time you do
something you're like I have so much
regrets about this are so nice too cuz I
posted it on my story and stuff on
Instagram and everyone's like it's okay
like you can't even touch it I can't
[ __ ] told no one I saw it yeah
stories it was more noticeable but here
I didn't even notice
yeah cuz I don't have the aligners in I
will say we do we don't call you metal
mouth we call you clear mouth
I'm gonna be your mouth plastic hate I
hate it yeah we want you to be butthurt
did you ever have to do that thing where
you like make your mouth wider how do
you make your mouth wide okay it's so
like my mouth was too small to hold all
my teeth so I pushed all my teeth up
like this so when I first got braces on
they had to put this like device on the
roof of my mouth and you had a crank and
every night with the key it was the most
painful Jack it up like a tire and I'd
be crying and she'd be like what is your
mouth and then it created this huge gap
in front of my teeth because it's before
the braces get put on and it was like my
first day of school freshman year at a
new high school with the clear wax that
they you use on your brain I mean it
looks like [ __ ]
better than a gap but yeah when you say
clear mouth I'm like oh I remember that
that hurt a little bit too close yeah my
dad everything out recently got braces
isn't it is like almost and she had
braces before but then like she didn't
wear the retainer all the time cuz I got
braces and I was 20 or 21 oh yeah so it
needs to be readjusted cuz braces just
put it back like put it in the nicer
shape right so what happened was like I
had them on for two years and I got them
off and the retainer I had it broke so I
never went back to replace it so then
years went by and fixed like I didn't
get a retainer and my teeth shifted and
then we were gonna get married I didn't
want to have like crooked eyes teeth for
our wedding they weren't that bad anyway
but I did those like mail in things like
the mail in aligners others yeah so then
they kind of worked but it didn't work
as good and like my teeth were so weird
after you get braces removed
are you still supposed to wear retainers
to keep it yeah forever for life
really so your your teeth just don't
adjust anymore well that's why when you
get older yet you still have to get it
if you don't do it for long yeah you
don't worry Tina that's why
it's a late life crisis age limit like
if you get to a certain age you
shouldn't be allowed to get braces
thinking yo I'm gonna live another like
20 years like I want to have some stray
testis people hit like [ __ ] they're
just big dentures and pasty you don't
need to natural Lacey's not like the
ladies the girls store the whiskers and
[ __ ] on my damn have you given up on her
I had my braces on a year longer than I
was supposed to have a mom cuz I had to
get those rubber bands that go across
their whole what are those do yeah is
that a cross bite so like a my jaw
didn't line up I was all [ __ ] up like
a cross bite is when your teeth like my
so your jaw supposed to be like this
because I know under I don't under buy
it I know I went like this yeah so I had
to get rubber bands to pull them back
together but they hurt like a [ __ ] and
they go across your whole mouth so like
you can't we talk it like look stupid
and then like when you eat like it's hot
you did it cuz I didn't do it didn't so
that's why I had to keep them on longer
it's like when you go to exercise you're
like I want to be a skinny [ __ ] and
then you like do a week and you're like
hard I've been trying to be a skinny
[ __ ]
so I used the retainer like I never took
the retainer I got I didn't ever want to
braces on again you did good but then I
stepped on it after late eight months I
think because I never took the retainer
off so huge like six months to really
got it yeah I had like midnight snacks
7-eleven and he had like a diagonal bite
yeah it's a cross bite to the extreme no
but now I got some cookies yes no my
daughter moved in I think I wanna be off
the market soon guys I think I'll be no
relationship in what way women like
daughters you're like oh she he's a good
dad it's time and I've been single for
the past couple years huh
oh I'm Tori like I'm 40 I like men
single Authority you don't like 40s oh
I'm a mature Asian don't wring this is
no reason I've never heard that white is
right last time I was here man calves
are on a weight loss competition I
remember I was up at 3 o'clock in the
morning with a [ __ ] sauna suit bag on
running low I was eating nothing but
lettuce and protein shakes he was I did
I lost like 40 but he it was just like
we're all torn it was just too difficult
yeah it's hard you don't have a routine
and it's hard on your mental it's like
you're getting all playing into
different stuff so yeah I'm still trying
to lose my last 25 pounds but yeah we
stopped
did all of you guys in the crude try to
live yeah yeah cuz I know to here just
like here lots of much away - yeah so he
was in the bed - and even though we
caught it off he's still collected on
the best I still paid him money gave
your word
minimal work so you know it was a stupid
bet on my beer at the time that I
started I was like 315 320 and I was
like I'm gonna weigh less than you Kevin
and Kevin was 260 at the time stacked
against us and then to here was I want
to get me on the wrong way less than you
too [ __ ] so I was gonna go against him
and so then I got down to like 275 and
campus still like it - sissies all the
closer I saw him and I think Sahir
dropped like 38 pounds but I still I
dropped the most but that wasn't the bet
the bet was it was a stupid bet it's
like like if you like you would win more
because it's against it's not in your
favor damn well tech I'd do the same
thing because if you aim really high you
actually go past more than what you ever
would you lost more like 50 pounds from
315 to about 275 so roughly whatever
that is map wise that's huge 40 pounds
like you know I'm saying I'm happy with
that but as [ __ ] up as I feel like
when you're fat
like you know like nobody cares like I
lost 40 pounds like you still yeah
because it's the before and after you
want to see the after shot
we won't tell us your during got to like
someone else's before right this is I
lost 40 pounds I'd look at our exes yeah
exactly that's a whole lot of weight
well that's a lot exactly but I mean but
from my original starting place I should
be a lot bigger 486 whoa hold on so you
guys you guys never seen that for 86 so
you all should be great so this that's
what it used to be how'd you leave that
what highway lost out of 2015
why did you gotta we're cool I was being
ridiculous
and you still had a lot of ladies oh
yeah I saw ya not was never fat ugly I
feel like if you were if you're fat cuz
most bad people are cute really really
fat really ugly really like grotesque
but if you have a confidence and a good
personality
you know Santa's girl there's so much
nicer than guys yeah they are yeah
because they have all these standards
and then like if you connect with them
emotionally it just disappears okay you
said that you're you're gonna be off the
market soon are you circling a target do
you have someone know the girl that I
think I'm just like did you meet her at
the bar you're dating her actually no no
I actually met her I slim her dance you
gotta verify check mark symbol is that
it she was like oh I don't have a blue I
don't have a blue check either I judge
people that I have a blue check thing
very much
your silence non-blue checker what is
your philosophy on fan [ __ ] are you
pro are you a game mom with it yeah
right it's important that you against it
I don't but you also have a difference
like age demographic of fans too so it
depends on like what your demographic
goes we have 50 year old fans that's why
but the biggest thing though the girl
that I'm dating it is a big age
difference what is it she's like 14 my
name is 26 no I mean anything over 20
the biggest gap is the biggest gap I've
ever had but anything over 24 I just
feel like who cares right but it's just
it's like you have to do it with a
[ __ ] Playboy Bunnies the same [ __ ]
yeah but what the hell did they talk
about I think nothing right like hey
we're watching Gilmore Girls is like the
[ __ ] you I think okay so so the way
that it will work is if a very immature
man in a very mature young lady yeah
match each other man that's what I think
we are yes but she was six years old
during 9/11 18 years yeah 8 years old 8
years old yes excuse me she was in 2nd
grade not first that's why I'm and I'm
I'm excited about it man I'm ready for
that man sorry to hear about your
breakup are you are you able to talk
about it or not that's a different
author I think you could talk about it
t-mike wipe your mouth and the drool are
you doing okay though yeah yeah no it's
I think it's like one of those things
where it was good timing because it
didn't come out of nowhere and we both
try gave it our hardest so then I don't
know man I would say it's one of the
best breakups I've ever had and it's
weird to say that well you got a cut no
you got any drama
you got a cry yeah [ __ ] me about
relationships I think about this whole
time you're like you're with my for five
years right talk to maybe they spent
other time and then probably like it
three or four months you probably won't
even talk to this person anymore that's
it Frank buck to me like that we do that
with each other like well yeah I mean
the she's gonna be a part of my life
still because she's a part of the
company like she's close with all my
friends and I think that's freaking
awesome it's because we haven't been
romantic in the past like years so it's
almost like being we've been roommates
just trying to like bring it back
together
ignite yeah and then just even just get
along but I think I get along with her
really well as a friend more than as a
romantic part it sounds like a very
mature breakup man it is that's why I
want to keep her around like because
it's like it's almost like family now
man and then so I can probably be like
Oh in a couple years
I probably like be like let me vet the
guys you're with or whatever like this
one alright he's cool whatever like a
brother right yeah so it's a different
feeling you know if you're a bigger man
than me man I'm just old Patti could
never even imagine doing that oh if she
was a shady piece of [ __ ] it would be
different yeah you know how hard it is
to find someone that's just genuine dope
everyone's a selfish Sadie she's like
weird you know so when you when I find
my philosophy is when you find those
people you want to keep them around
quality people to have in your life yeah
man and just cuz you're not [ __ ]
anymore it's like what's the point cuz
out of the romance and whatever there's
still a good person yeah
nothing I've been guilty of that my
relationships in the past I felt like
I'd burn it down into the ground because
I feel like it's not gonna work it I
feel like I need to be more mature like
you oh man I'm forced to be it wasn't my
choice
[Laughter]
absolutely if that person was a [ __ ]
person though I'm all for burning it
together yeah you gotta burn something
to the ground man if she was a garbage
can I think everybody would go after
listen I'm not friends with any of my
exes and I'm [ __ ] proud of it I would
wear a shirt that says that [ __ ] yes
it's a big garbage axis I'm friends with
one but that's because I have to be way
different no I mean we're cool it took
years though the mature place where
we're at and like he's really cool with
with my husband too so but it took a
while some time it's always like a
cowboy saying I thought no matter what
between guys no matter what even if it's
cool hey I'm Casey I'm cool with you and
Jed there's always like a [ __ ] cowboy
standoff and behind the eyes absolutely
yeah I don't think that would happen
with me cuz it's either I charmed them
or when if Jess wasn't there and then
he's there I'd whisper in years a year
that I can slit his throat at any moment
but why he hurts her feelings like he's
like you know how many years I wanted to
be her and I still didn't do it so you
better not [ __ ] do it I hurt her
feelings you don't get to her
[Music]
[Music]